kannst du dich bitte verpissen sonne
hallo mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren heute bin ich nun hier soll sind
mir bei twitter einige eurer
hausaufgaben die ja heute so in der
schule auch bekommen hat zu senden
posten unter dem hashtag lehrer luca und
das habt ihr zahlreich getan
ich wusste nicht dass so viele von euch
doch in die schule gehen ich habe mir
nun hier auf jeden fall einige zettel
rausgesucht ich habe mir einen edding
rausgenommen ich habe mir einen
textmarker ausgenommen einen
kugelschreiber
wer den mann so oft verschiedene farben
machen kann und jetzt habe ich
beispielsweise rot runter und jetzt kann
ich ja normalerweise schreibt er auch
auf jeden fall würde ich sagen wir regt
damit der erste hausaufgabe besteck
lehrer luca das ist bio und oben drüber
steht die aufgabenstellung wie finden
wir heraus wer in f2 ryanair blick ist
vorschlage rück kreuzung mit dem
rezessiven patria und der f2 generation
was das hier ist die aufgabe die er mir
geschickt hsv alter cool hast ein ipad
also die aufgabenstellung ist wie finden
wir heraus wer in f23 nervig es was
heißt rainer beckmann
ich würde sagen wir machen weiter mit
der nächsten aufgabe wie kommt hier von
der linie
sie schreibt viel spaß beim mathe und
wenn du es wirklich schafft kriegst du
fünf euro
danke das hier ist die aufgabe die sie
mir geschickt hatte also es ist eine
trainings aufgabe überprüfen ob die
angegebene zahl eine lösung der
gleichung ist 2 -17 gleich neun das
heißt
das wenn ich das jetzt lösen müsste
würde ich erst mal ein strich am rand
setzen +17 rechnen das heißt wir haben
zwei ex gleich 26 dann würde ich durch
zwei teilen und swx einzelnen stehen
haben das ist 13
das heißt ja ich stelle 13 ist richtig
und meine liebe lily ich würde sagen du
recht ist jetzt zweiter also habe ich
dir jetzt schon ausgerechnet bei b ist
es dann fünf x3 gleich drei top fünf da
müssten man das ixs auf eine seite
bringen uns die zahlen ohne variable auf
die andere seite und dann zu gucken ob
das die wehr steht die rics gleich vier
ob das eine richtige lösung ist fünf
euro bitte auf mein konto geld steckt
lehrer du kannst das sind meine
hausaufgaben
diese scheiß jugend von heute ich muss
aufgabe 17 bis 19 machen würde mich sehr
über die hilfe von herr hashtag lehrer
freuen
erstmal sollte ist so groß und
kleinschreibung und dramatik üben aber
bei der aufgabe hier geht es ja um mathe
das ist die achte heilige scheiße sie
dass viele zahl alter viel spaß das ist
relativ easy und zwar sind das sieben
acht zehntel und 718 sind 78 ich bin zu
auch man kann mich auch buchen bei der
internetseite lautet superminister von
de apropos shop.de erwarten heute muster
phase das heißt von den designs die ich
mir überlegt habe sind die ersten muster
schon angekommen und leute es wird mal
wieder sehr litt am 16 um 15 uhr im
lukas ein produkt werde ich euch jetzt
sogar schon mal zeigen und zwar ist es
dieser politik wird schleswig-holstein
tatsächlich ist ihr aufgefallen und hier
auf der brust wenn man mal ran sind
jetzt im körper sieht man das ist ein
kleines gesticktes alpaka tut mir so ein
bisschen im ralph lauren stil halten
also dass sie wird auf jeden fall ein
rudi der am ersten sechs in den shop
kombi aber hier bestätigen uns heute mit
mir weiter hier luca luka wenn du
französisch kannst ich habe zwar nie
französisch ich hatte immer nur latein
aber wieso specker dass er nicht seinen
onkel jugendrichtern blüht ja dämon
trikot sinus alpha rosinus alltag und
quadrat plus cosinus alfa - alpha
quadrat gleich zwei simply 47 du ich
wünsche ganz ganz viel spaß mit einer
französischen mutter scheiße aber für
mich ist das nicht schreibt nummer vier
bis sieben viel spaß und danke
hersteller sogar um den
mathe aufgaben man bestimmen sie die
obere grenze iks des integral so dass
das integral den wert 12 hat ex größer 0
aufgabe langes s3d quadrat tipps
[Musik]
ich drücke aber ganz doll die daumen die
mission sharing lief ganz gut ich zum
weltfrauentag an meine frau hier mal
chemie und mathe viel spaß und das hier
sind die acht aufgaben seid ihr auf
einer schule in der folterkammer bei der
umsetzung von 34 gramm natrium nitrat
mit konzentrierter schwefelsäure
entstehenden 21 gramm reine
salpetersäure berechnet die ausbeute im
prozent ich habe da mal was vorbereitet
und ich glaube ich würde dass angelina
ich wünsche euch viel spaß bei chemie
und mathematik lehrer luca in geografie
beziehungsweise erdkunde in englischer
wirtschaftssprache müssen wir dazu ein
diagramm zeichnen das dem
bevölkerungswachstum von dieser angabe
entspricht und das hier ist die aufgabe
mit den fünf stage is also sie muss ja
ein diagramm zeichnen in dieser aufgabe
das heißt die beantwortung würde ich
sagen ist das hier
ich habe ein diagramm gezeichnet ich
wollte ich ja danke ich freue mich auch
dass ich dir da weiterhelfen konnte hier
meine hausaufgaben aus der zwölften
klasse in bayern hausaufgaben das wlan
soll für mitarbeiter und kunden in 2 v
ladens getrennt werden der access point
unterstützt multi ssid erläutern sie in
diesem zusammenhang zwei wichtige
aufgaben von multi ssid es sollte
funktionieren vorlagen können dynamisch
oder statisch eingerichtet werden
erläutern sie den prinzipiellen
unterschied zwischen den beiden
einrichtungen wie das eines dynamischen
und das andere statisch eurem gerät zu
lang da kann man sich noch einiges
beibringen teilstück lehrer luca ich
verstehe das nicht eine sorge dafür bin
ich doch da
ließ die rätsel wenn man 327 zu einer
zahl addiert erhält man 999 672 rätsel
gelöst
addiert man zum vierfachen einer zahl
das achtfache derselben zahl so erhält
man 108 ja das kannst du ja dann machen
wir lehrer luca meine hausaufgaben ist
bio ok erstens daran kann man die
unterschiedlichen vogelarten erkennen
ihrem aussehen zweitens etwa die hälfte
aller vogelarten sind vögel die hälfte
aller vögel sind vögel und die hälfte
ist auch vögel dritten sie muss viel
üben das vogelküken muss üben zu fliegen
viertens diesen vogel hört man besonders
oft flugzeug
fünftens er ist gar kein singen vogel 6
sie fliegen in den süden deutsche im
winter 17
dieser vogel bleibt im winter in
österreich der österreichische vogel der
nicht fliegen kann also wenn die
schnitzel fifa besonders bei fifa
spielen behalten ich habe keinen plan
was man da machen muss aber vielleicht
du hashtag lehrer du kannst
ich auch nicht vom luca mach meine
hausaufgaben das ist tatsächlich eine
englische ausgabe und englisch weil ich
eigentlich immer relativ gut deswegen
will ich sagen haben direkt am mittag
henry mit models and rush kronhardt
frohnauer oder graffitis besprayt und
power ball laufen lässt du ri bikes
wurst dohlen kommende school ja keine
garantie eine aufgabe fünf häfen die
aufgabe 50 ziemlich geschickt hat laut
hitze gegeben sei die funktion elf durch
fmx gleich 0,5 xq ich hasse hatte den
buchstaben dazu kommen erst kannst du
selbst machen das ist meine hause in
englisch ich muss was über den
buckingham palace herausfinden in den
ferien es ist mitte märz sie kann denn
jetzt ferien haben was ist denn das märz
ferien aber würde ich hätte trotzdem
weiter natürlich hier in den ferien
die erste frage ist wo er ist bis heute
in london zweite aufgabe how to you get
der wills ganzen laufen kannst du einen
schwimm krabbeln oder purzelbaum
drittens what can you der auch alles
ganz reingehen kann dort drauf klettern
kann zuvor einen salto machen oder
danforth packen allerdings würde ich
sagen kommen wir nicht auch zum ende von
nachhilfe lehrer luca weil ich muss auch
noch ein paar hausaufgaben arbeiten
korrigieren wir beenden die heutige
folge lehrer mit dieser aussage ich habe
keine hausaufgaben auf herzlichen
glückwunsch
nico hermes wirklich klasse ich glaube
ich hatte noch nie keine hausaufgaben
auf an einem schultag allerdings nicht
das heutige video und der stelle jetzt
auch beenden seine liebe freunde ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen mir hat und
ihm viel spaß gemacht ich hoffe ich
konnte euch weiterhelfen
ihr seid jetzt ein bisschen klüger und
wir sehen uns dann nächste woche wieder
wenn es wieder heißt
nach hilft euch ja
[Musik]